welcome to bananamores this next comic
is a bananamaw's instant legend
please give it up for grace writer
so growing up i watched a ton of
cartoons and
i found myself attracted to well a lot
of cartoon characters so i thought it
would be kind of fun if we
i don't know took a stroll down memory
lane and recounted
some of my old cartoon crushes so
in no particular order we have danny
phantom and
i like danny phantom because he had
white hair
super powers and he wore a spandex suit
really did not take much for me next we
have uh
number one or nigel uno from coding kids
next store
and i liked him because he had a fat
girlfriend
and she actually really looked like me
she had glasses and brown hair and was
fat and of course being insecure
growing up i was like nobody's ever
gonna love me even a cartoon character
but he was into fat girls so i was like
i could really see this working out for
both of us
so that was really exciting to finally i
don't know see me like represented in
media
i guess i am white so i would whatever
but like the fat part
okay next we have simon from alvin in
the chipmunks
and he i liked him because
he had glasses again
very the bar's low bar's very low and he
wore a blue sweatshirt
and so and blue was my favorite color at
the time because
i was like ew pink's gross and boys like
the color blue and i'm kind of like a
boy cause i'm a tomboy and
i don't like skirts they're stupid so i
was really fun to be around
i think if i'm being honest like deep
down i really had a crush on alvin i
just
didn't want to admit it because i knew
like he would i don't know he wouldn't
be into me like that because
i don't know everyone's cool like the
whole name like the band is literally
alvin and the chipmunks like
i don't know it's like donald's work but
he's like a total tool
anyways so it's i kind of dodged a
bullet you know elven
is the side thing the side hustle the
hook up the toxic
college boyfriend that you met on like
tinder or something
i say totally having gone to college for
only one semester and deleting tinder
after like
two seconds because i didn't want people
to like perceive me
but simon's the chip monkey marry so
whatever i dodgeable
next we have nick wilde and i like wild
because he
was a bad boy with a heart of gold he
was a criminal yes
which was also kind of hot too but he
didn't want to be a criminal he was only
a criminal
because that the cards he was dealt with
in life and he's like
hey like i'm nick wilde i'm different
like don't talk to me um he
like if he was a person he'd probably
wear like a black leather jacket or
something
and i don't know i was like he's
different like if
i got to know him i could change him you
know what i mean that's like the kind of
vibe i get from him and
you know you get to know him and you
realize yeah he's just a normal fox
and he's you know he he
built these barriers because life gave
him
these cards and he's d i keep going with
on the card sing but
you know what i mean anyways you can
change them as what i'm getting at but
you can't change elephant
but i can already see you guys right now
you're probably like wait a minute
zootopia came out in 2016. don't you
think
that's a little old to be liking a
cartoon fox be considering you were 16
when the movie came out
and to that i reply actually no that's
pretty normal i think it's totally
normal to have a crush on an
anthropomorphic fox
when you're 16 years old what else what
else am i gonna do
this isn't euphoria okay
like normal teens have crushes on foxes
not whatever they do in euphoria um next
we have
lola from shark tales um
she's a betta fish she's really hot
she's kind of like the jessica rabbit of
fish
yeah that's pretty much it she's
universally hot in the sense like
everyone thought she was hot
um and last but not least we have elsa
uh the queen
the queen and i liked elsa for the same
reasons i liked
uh danny phantom she had white hair
super powers and although she didn't
wear a spandex suit she did have a
really tight-fitted dress
with a slit in it and i remember in the
theater when i watched that i was like
this movie's pg-13
i don't think this kid should be she was
walking like
that was really great i was like i'll
think about that later
um but other than that yeah that's
pretty much
those are pretty much like obviously
that's not a comprehensive list if it
was
we would be here all day but that's just
a little taste
taste of my childhood crushes i can't
even get over how much
talent this person has kind of unfair
give a little to the rest of us